[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american romantic
comedy called the invention of lying
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie starts with a man narrating
about a world where humans have evolved
into beings who cannot tell a lie
because of this everyone speaks the
truth including the beggars businessmen
and even the beloved president himself
the narrator introduces mark bellison as
a loser who is about to change his luck
by telling the world's first lie
in the first scene mark approaches a
beautiful woman named anna to take her
on a first date anna remarks with
frustration that mark disturbed her
while she was pleasuring herself she
also comments that mark is early and
needs to wait for her to get ready mark
expresses his concern that he can only
afford a cheaper restaurant he further
says that his boss will probably fire
him in the next week and he does not
possess any financial assets despite
being in his late 40s anna comes down
and states that she does not find mark
attractive enough mark who is used to
getting similar attention from women
sighs as they come out of the room the
two then enter a restaurant where the
waiter is also brutally honest with them
he comments that anna is out of mark's
league and asks if she is his daughter
embarrassed mark thanks him and asks him
to leave he then asks anna about herself
she replies that she has a job that pays
well so she is thriving in life she gets
a phone call from her mother and tells
her that mark is not good looking and
does not earn well upon her mother's
query she answers that she is neither
kissing nor sharing the bed with him
tonight as they leave mark thanks anna
for seeing him the scene moves to the
lecture films studio where a man is
demonstrating napoleon's story as mark
appears the man introduces him to the
crowd as a screenplay writer of the
company mark greets them with a smile
which soon changes to embarrassment when
the man truthfully announces mark to be
one of the least successful employees
who is getting fired soon mark arrives
at the office and gets teased by his
colleague shelly for his incompetence
the boss anthony comes out and fires
mark for his pathetic writing about the
black plague at the same time mark
discovers anna's mail stating that
despite liking his company she is not
interested in him on account of his
genetic looks financial condition and
position in life which are all of the
determinants for marrying people shelley
rubs salt into mark's wounds with her
honesty saying that the best part of the
male is about his bad looks when mark
walks out of his office shelly and brad
mark's competitor say that they've
always loathed mark working with them
brad further says that mark will always
be a loser this is a lot of truth bombs
for one day what did these people talk
about before
mark then enters a nursing home which in
this world is called a sad place for
hopeless old people he is there to see
his mother martha bellison he tells
martha about losing his job he stresses
that his mother is a loser too and they
come from a long line of losers later at
home mark's landlord approaches him
asking for the rent after mark shares
his condition the landlord gives him a
single day to get his stuff out of the
house because he is no longer competent
to pay the rent mark goes to a bank to
close his account and withdraw all the
money he has the cashier informs him
that they cannot help him close the
account because the system is down but
they can provide him the cash the
cashier then asks him his saving amount
as they cannot see him through the
system mark says that he wants 800
while his heart beats rapidly just then
the system comes back and the cashier
checks his account which has only 300
the cashier says that the system might
have been faulty and believes mark
instead she gives him 800
and apologizes for the system's fault
mark is astonished to receive this
amount that he does not have in his
account and he leaves the bank with a
huge smile he pays his rent and returns
to his room an overwhelmed mark shares
to his friends about his deed being
unfathomable he has just discovered
lying but his friends who are unfamiliar
with the concept do not understand him
mark tests his new skill by changing his
name every few minutes and his friends
believe him every time then he asks his
friends what they would do first if they
could do anything in the world greg says
that he would have intercourse with a
girl so to try it mark goes outside and
calls a girl past him she ignores him at
first but stops at once when mark
mentions that the world will end if she
does not have sex with him at this
moment the girl hurriedly takes a
surprised mark to a motel when they
reach there mark asks the girl to
introduce herself but the girl shouts
that they have to do it soon for the
sake of the world mark feels awkward
himself and pretends to make a call to
nasa he says that nasa has confirmed the
world will not end and they need not
sleep together huh rectifying a lie with
another lie mark is on the fast track to
becoming a politician following this he
returns to his friends and asks them
aside from being with a girl what would
they do if they could do anything in the
world they cannot think of anything and
in turn ask mark what he would do at
once mark replies that he would get all
the money in the world all this room
aspires to is misogyny and greed this is
dark after that mark and greg go for a
ride as greg drives the car totally
drunk a police officer stops them and
tries to arrest greg for drunk driving
but when mark simply states that his
friend is not drunk the officer believes
him he even apologizes and leaves the
scene the friends enter a casino where
mark insists on playing roulette he
plays his chance on 28 but sees that the
roulette is marked 35 so he slyly points
and yells at everyone to look at
something unusual ahead as everybody
looks away mark drags his bet to 35 and
claims it the dealer doesn't doubt him
and provides mark with his prize in a
similar way mark cheats several times
and comes out of the casino with a large
sum later he meets his depressed friend
frank in an elevator who shares that he
is about to commit suicide mark thinks
about it and tells frank that he does
not need to kill himself frank believes
him and they both plan to hang out later
that night mark uses the technique he
has discovered to bring happiness to
people's lives that's more like it mark
one night mark calls anna and asks her
on another date he explains that he has
changed and anna should see it herself
anna agrees to go out with him for the
last time after hanging the phone up
mark turns his tv on and sees a lecture
film show in which the narrator praises
brad's writing mark gets an idea from
this and goes to his table to write a
story with his newfound knowledge after
completing it he pours tea onto it and
makes it look like a historical script
mark heads to the lecture film studio
and tells his boss anthony that he has
discovered historical writing in an
ancient chest buried in a desert the
writing has stories about the crashing
of a giant spaceship in babylon and it
catches anthony's attention he asks his
employees to listen to the historic
story as mark recites it mark reads that
the earth was saved by aliens in the
14th century he adds that the alien king
wiped out humans memories to prevent
them from remembering the events after
700 years a great writer mark bellison
would stumble on and be put to human
acknowledgement after being fired by his
crappy boss anthony and mocked by his
colleagues shelby and brad the last
sentence of the script says that the
lecture films will be making a
successful film and mark will become
famous and wealthy everyone applauds
believing the absurd writing while brad
is upset anthony asks mark to get to
work on that film soon the next day mark
takes anna to an expensive restaurant
for their date anna congratulates mark
for selling his script and asks about
his family mark shares that his father
is an alcoholic and his mother is in a
nursing home he plans to take her out of
the nursing home the next day and get
her a mansion mark finally asks anna if
she wants to spend her life with him
since he is now wealthy and successful
though anna likes him for his wealth and
success she rejects him because of his
appearance and remarks that she does not
want her kids to be fat with snub noses
disappointed mark takes a sip of his
drink and answers a phone call he finds
out that his mother is in critical
condition and rushes to the hospital on
her deathbed martha shares that she is
frightened of dying for it is an
eternity of nothingness as her vitals
drop mark lies to his mother saying that
she will be in her favorite place after
death young and juvenile together with
her loved ones as martha hears this she
smiles with excitement and soon passes
away the doctor and nurses who just
heard mark talk to his mother ask him to
talk more about life after death but
saddened by the loss mark returns back
home with anna as they wake up the next
morning they share smiles knowing that
they slept on each other's shoulders the
whole night later mark drives to his
home to find a big crowd in front of it
astonished he gets past the group while
a woman screams his name the crowd
quickly surrounds mark asking about
events that will happen after death he
somehow gets inside the house and turns
the tv on to see a journalist reporting
the scene from outside soon anna comes
to his house and asks mark what he said
to his mother he shares everything with
her and anna believes in it instantly
she insists that mark tell the people
everything he knows though in a dilemma
mark reaches for his pen and paper and
starts writing after he is done he comes
out and reads it aloud to the crowd he
says that there is a man in the sky who
knows everything the man will provide
people with the best mansion free ice
cream and loved ones in the place after
they die he warns that people who do bad
things three times in their life will be
placed in terrible areas while people
curse the man in the sky for causing bad
events mark convinces them that the man
is also responsible for all the good
events happening to people's lives one
of the women comes forth and questions
mark how he knows all of this mark
replies that the man in the sky told him
about it and leaves while the crowd
clamors
the following day's news headlines make
titles like nasa on the search of the
man in the sky lowering the work
productivity for people thinking about
mansions after death and the man in the
sky responsible for disasters and
miracles mark goes to his office and
hands over the writing of the black
plague to his boss the film becomes a
super hit and mark gets rich and famous
overnight while sitting in a park mark
remarks to anna that she is the sweetest
person he has ever met anna also says
that she enjoys his company they get
close to kissing but anna backs away at
the thought of her children looking like
ricky gervais she expresses that she
loves him but cannot get past the
genetics thing later that day anna comes
to mark's mansion to give him a birthday
card and informs him that she is going
on a date with brad she also shares
about her intentions of sleeping with
brad which mark finds alarming he
convinces anna not to be involved in
physical relations with anyone before
marriage after saying this mark opens
his birthday card which has a birthday
coupon for him to share the bed with her
she complains that since they are not
married she will not go out of the rule
mark finds himself awkward and says that
it is a shame to waste this coupon just
then brad arrives and takes anna to
dinner throughout the dinner he talks
about his success and belittles mark for
his appearance while anna watches mark's
interview on tv her mom changes the
channel saying that mark is never going
to be her friend even though he speaks
to the man in the sky anna does not like
her talking about mark like that and
argues that he makes her feel special
the mother strongly opposes anna with
the argument that mark will always be a
loser and his children will be the same
she calls brad at that moment and
insists that anna talked to him many
weeks pass after the event one day anna
suddenly appears in front of mark and
finds him looking awful with long hair
and a beard she gives him the invitation
card to her wedding and asks him to
attend it for her mark requests that she
does not marry brad but anna replies
that she needs to do this because she
has little time to match a perfect
genetic partner and have the children
she has always longed for on the day of
anna's wedding mark wakes up and sees
greg in a suit who offers him a shaver
he shaves his beard and attends the
wedding the priest asks the people if
they offer a better genetic match-up as
silence prevails mark stands and puts
forth his claim that anna is happier
with him brad in turn asks mark why anna
is standing next to him if she is happy
with mark brad tells mark to ask the man
in the sky what's best for anna to which
mark says that anna knows what is best
for her mark begins to walk out but anna
insists he asked the man in the sky mark
finally confesses that there is no man
in the sky and he just told the story to
relieve his mother during her death anna
further questions why he did not lie to
marry her mark replies that the lie
would not make a count at last anna
claims that she wants little fat kids
with snub noses hearing this puts a
smile on mark's face as the movie
concludes mark and anna are seen eating
breakfast with their chubby little son
while anna is pregnant with their second
child
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching